[Music]
you have to work with flavors and smells
and touch and sight
but you also have to hear what's going
on
that balance of all five senses sort of
is a tipping point where
you can do just about anything
with our candy we look back in time we
go back to the 1800s the victorian
period many of our bits of equipment
were made in that time period we're
pretty much the only one who has started
up again using the sort of equipment
tracking it down and restoring it
today we're going to be making sugar
plum drop candies eggnog image candies
and peppermint candy
canes first we do the candy canes
the first thing we do is we cook the
sugar
it's mixed with water and we're boiling
all the water out we need to use two
sugars to interrupt the crystallization
process sucrose and glucose if we just
use sugar and water when it hardened it
would turn back into table sugar and
become granular hot pot
we have a team of five candy makers here
at lofty pursuits hurry and jake were
working with me today
everybody in the store knows when we
make peppermint candy because peppermint
has a weird reaction to your skin it
makes you feel cool if anybody was in
any way slightly congested or had any
matter of allergies at this point they
will not after that 25 pounds of candy
canes only take less than an ounce of
peppermint oil
when we make candy with multiple colors
in it we add the food coloring on the
table we do this so we can segment and
separate the different areas of color
one of our specialized tools doesn't
look like it's a tool it's a giant table
the top is made out of a half inch piece
of steel and has a water circulation
system in it we use it to rapidly cool
the hot sugar
where it comes in contact with the table
will cool off quickly but the bits not
in contact don't cool that fast so by
folding the candy together we get to
even out the heat and pick the
temperature we want we may want it to
act more like a liquid or more like a
solid or somewhere in between
all right we're getting real close to
stretch time
next we make the amber sugar white
this is a hand wrought iron hook it's
thicker than most of the other hooks
that we encountered this lets it radiate
the heat better so the candy is less
likely to stick to the hook we have
several hooks in the store but the one
that i used today came from a store
called mullaine's which was opened in
1848 in cincinnati
we changed the amber into white we
pulled it about 75 times each time we
folded it it trapped air bubbles on the
inside those air bubbles are great
because those little round bubbles
reflect light back out and the random
light that they reflect appears white
then we start making the stripes on the
heating table make sure my stripes are
super
even in thickness candy canes didn't
always have stripes the first candy
canes were white actually if you look at
victorian greeting cards which is the
best way to look at the history of candy
canes because they showed up on them it
wasn't until the late 1800s the first
stripes came out and this is partially
because people thought of peppermint as
a white color i'm just waiting for these
to actually get stuck together
one of the things about candy that we
have to be careful with is the colors
will migrate from one part to another in
the candy canes if they're too hot the
red would actually bleed into the white
parts of the candy and we don't want
this to happen we do this by controlling
the temperature and the only way we can
really tell the temperature at this
point is by feel we know how stiff the
candy needs to be and that just comes
with practice
[Music]
income
the batch roller twists the candy as it
forces it down the taper we don't want
it to go too far but it's kind of useful
in this case to a point because it puts
a spiral on the candy cane
the first candy cane is born
we add a spiral with our hands but we do
it at the machine first
then we add the hook on the candy cane
the hook on the top of the candy cane is
made by bending it if you think of this
it's behaving like a tube the inside
white is softer than the outside so we
have to bend it very carefully we use
our hands in a very similar way to a
tube bender that a plumber uses then we
have a little guide we use to make sure
they're all a consistent size
and that's how we make candy canes
next we'll make the drop candy
[Music]
we start the process the same boiling
the sugar and adding the flavor
the sugar plum is a drop candy where
everything is the same color everything
else we did use multiple colors because
of this we could cheat a little we could
add the coloring and the flavoring in
the pot at the same time hot pot
and when we poured it on the table we
could pour it thinner and over a larger
surface areas will cool faster
it just speeds up the candy making
process
we can tell by the texture of the sugar
the temperature of the sugar and then we
add the citric acid because citric acid
will burn if the sugar's too hot and the
citric acid is the acid that makes the
flavors right
most of these flavors come with no acid
in them and most fruits have acid in it
just gets like impossibly thin
the problem with teaching candy making
is it's all about touch
the consistency changes constantly
there's one point that we want to cut it
we want to cut it when the outside is
hard and the inside's still liquid so we
can average out the temperatures you can
see it's like starting to become a
little bit more compact but then when we
want to manipulate it we wanted more of
a clay consistency when we're doing the
initial shape but we wanted to get
harder to keep the shapes once it's done
it went from a liquid to now it's
behaving like a non-newtonian fluid and
that means that right now it's flowing
like a liquid but if we put a lot of
pressure in it it would behave like a
solid
i still have a pair of scissors for my
great grandfather when he was a tailor
and they probably took
two weeks of salary to buy
but he kept them for a lifetime and he
died before i was born
the things that i own here for this
candy making i don't feel like i'm an
owner of i'm just a caretaker of
because they're going to be here
generations after me and i have to
preserve them for the candy makers that
follow me
this is
150 year old equipment
the machine is a fruit drop roller we're
doing this by passing the candy through
it and getting out the shape at the
other end
today we use the diamond shape
the diamond candy not only looks pretty
but gives eight surfaces to be in your
mouth so the flavor spreads faster so we
like this for subtle flavors like the
sugar plum
these candy machines haven't changed
much in the last 150 years they were
developed by thomas mills in brothers in
philadelphia these machines are made out
of cast iron they weigh 20 or 30 pounds
each and the rollers are solid bronze
everything needs to be non-stick on this
and like a cast iron skillet we've made
it non-stick by working in oil to the
surface
i'm going to pre-cool some some chunks
over here the candy comes out of the
machine onto the candy cooling table
water is being sprayed on the underside
of the top can't have water on the candy
would make it sticky this freezes the
candy in place as soon as it comes out
of the machine the rollers get it into
shape but it's a table itself that cools
it off
we slide it across the table when it's
still behaving about the consistency of
shoe leather it's not rock hard yet
the sheet of candy comes out connected
by sugar which we call flash the flash
holds the candy together when it comes
to the machine but now we need to get
rid of it we need to break the pieces
apart
and we do that by dropping the candy
[Applause]
the last thing we have to do is get rid
of all the sugar dust the remnants of
the flash we have to do this because the
candy under its own weight just like
glass to a certain point will fuse back
to itself
various candy makers use different
things i just use an old fryer that we
bought for this purpose
and that's how we make dropped candies
finally we'll make the eggnog cut rock
image candy
[Music]
we start the process the same boiling
the sugar and adding the flavor
hot pot
[Music]
i call it image candy the correct term
is cut rock it was originally invented
in blackpool england it's also sometimes
called blackpool rot
mmm smells like pink blackpool rock is
sold in a big piece with the art all the
way through like a stick of rock they
call it
what we're doing is we're taking into
bite-sized pieces which is the cut rock
part
okay well let's go
the metal of the equipment's important
all of our metal is mild steel not
stainless
stainless steel because of the very
nature that makes it not rust is not
magnetic sugar likes to stick to things
that are the same temperature is it and
the table if it heats up will become
sticky to the candy the bars if they
heat up too much will have come sticky
to the candy with the image candy
present we needed the inside to be cold
because we needed to keep the detail in
place
i say we should move to the table right
about now mine piece is good i don't
know if yours is a little hot but we
have time to cool it and i did this by
cooling off the corners of the presents
but we want the outside hotter so that
that candy can slide around it share its
heat and stretch it out so the image
will scale
[Music]
do you think that's enough for a little
more
a little bit
more one of the fun things about the
image candy is it's possibly the most
creative candy we do and some of the
most complex we have to create
three-dimensional art that's a good
shade in the case of the present we
wanted the inside color of the present
the light blue to be opaque
so when we put a clear blue wrap around
it light went through the clear blue
bounced back out and hit your eye and
looked more spectacular
beautiful that technique is called
cloisonne little boxes we're making a
little box for the light to bounce in
and out and by tapering the circles of
candy that i made sort of like candy
straws that are filled with white candy
i was able to make the illusion of a bow
or make the shape of the bow because
what good would a present be without a
bow but the bow is designed to be much
taller than it ended up
i let the weight of the candy being a
non-newtonian fluid get it to its final
shape
once we have the shape in the center we
pat it around with the white candy
this is for two reasons
one it gets it away from the outer edge
when the light goes through that wrap on
the edge of the present it bounces back
out at you
then we need to do an outer wrap of
unpulled candy the pulled candy are like
tiny little air bubbles so if we just
cut their white candy it might crumble
it might make a diagonal cut but if we
wrap it in the non-wrapped candy
non-pulled candy we're able to
create an outer level that'll produce a
crack around it when we cut it and make
smoother pieces
then we need to use gravity to make an
even taper our entire goal here is to
make a three-dimensional funnel of candy
we've learned how to stretch the image
down and scale it without losing the
detail without losing pieces and without
it distorting and that's what sometimes
takes years to master
next we put the candy on the batch
roller and we pull it before we had a
batch roller we had one person rolling
the candy while one person was pulling
it but now that person is replaced with
high technology high technology from
about 1910 and this badge roller spins
the candy
the candy is a non-newtonian fluid if we
just left that cylinder alone it would
go flat and spread out over the entire
table but by keeping it moving we keep
it as a solid object then we have to
pull it we have to pull it gently
because we pull it too fast it will snap
when it's thick so we're sort of pulling
it down gently scaling it with very very
even pressure
we then cut the pieces
[Music]
we do this on our canvas a little candy
anvil because we're sugar smiths
this elevates it off the table and
allows us to cut it with our chopper and
the knife hits it really hard
all the pieces become bite-sized and
each piece has an identical or nearly
identical image in it
people seem to forget that history isn't
that far away and the future isn't
either
and we're just sort of here in the
middle being a caretaker for what's
around us ideas people friendships loves
and if we can remember that everything's
as sweet as candy
you